compagne mais ici mais écoutez bien ce
que j'ai racontée à tous nos amis là
parce que voilà ce qui se passe par
exemple quand vous lisez un texte un
texte à haute voix quand vous faites par
exemple une dictée à un enfant ou
quelque chose comme ça vous dit la
ponctuation vous dit madiba data au
point un animal un virgule etc
c'est normal mais quand vous dites un
texte à haute voix comme ça pour
quelqu'un pour n'importe qui vous n'avez
pas besoin de dire la ponctuation c'est
pas nécessaire ça sert à rien et
pourtant si vous sonorise y est la
ponctuation c'est à dire si vous aimez
tier-1 petits sons qui correspondrait
aux points à la virgule etc
vous verriez que le texte vous êtes en
train de lire pour une dimension tout à
fait extraordinaire vous dire qu'est ce
qu'ils racontaient les pas du tout par
exemple le point nommé j'avais pensé à
sonoriser le point pouvait le faire chez
vous d'ailleurs le point
c'est très facile ça fait comme ceci
écoutez moi bien ça fait donc le point
ça fait la virgule la virgule c'est
cocasse et femina c'est esthétique une
virgule c'est très joli à regarder et
bien la virgule nous allons décider
ensemble ce soir que ça fait donc le
point ça paie et la virgule ça fait on
est d'accord pour voir si vous avez bien
compris que j'allais parmi vous dans la
salle je vais m'adresser à 2 3 personnes
pour voir non mais oui on rigole on
rigole mais on rigole pas tellement et
tenez je vais m'adresser à maxime bossis
maxime bossis dont je suis sûre cher
michel qu'en fin de carrière il aura un
nombre de sélections pratiquement
imbattable 1
j'ai bien l'impression et je vais lui
demander s'il a bien retenu la leçon de
me faire un p'tit coin les gilles aux
grands c'est pas mal et pourriez vous
s'il vous plaît
comme jean alesi on va demander là bas
pour voir écouter presse que vous n'êtes
pas non plus sorti de la berge comme
disait l'autre
alors monsieur je vois avec plaisir que
vous avez un physique il la rend vous
allez me faire le wat s'il vous plaît
oui oui tu jamais des poupées bella me
fait moins une virgule
c'est très bien mais bien côté c'est pas
compliqué nous allons faire une chose
d'importance avons divisé cette salle en
deux parties à gauche tous les points et
à droite toutes les virions cet accord
c'est très important ça part de là à
gauche tous les points à droite tous les
virgules
et chez vous dans votre salle à manger
ou dans votre salon vous divisez à
gauche les papilles à droite les mamies
et on y va et les enfants à tout le
monde
barret yahoo fait exactement la même
chose alors à gauche tous les points ça
fait donc et les buts ça fait donc alors
attention les points avec moi 1 2 3
puis simon peila
c'est par voie circuleront à signer les
propos hautement intellectuel de ce que
je viens de dire attention les virgules
1 2 3 c'est bien c'est très bien les
virgules bravo
attention maxime desbiens une équipe
attention 1 2 3 et que tout va changer
mais on change pas de place monsieur la
belle et gentille
alors j'ai continué savez comment on
fait le point la virgule nous allons
faire le poids bien compliqué il suffit
de mettre le point sur la vie recule
alors attention ça donne ceci écoutez
moi bien ça fait 1 2 3 voyez quand il
s'agit de monter les uns sur les autres
tout ça sera tout ça comme je connais ce
truc je copine le poids de suspension
après une suspension ça puisse aussi
c'était un 2/3 des glaces
le point d'interrogation alors pour
l'interrogation il et ventripotent il
est rendu iard il est sûr de lui c'est
pas facile ça fait ceci écoutez moi bien
ça fait attention
1 2 3 les yeux vous avez bien deviné
et voici maintenant le point
d'exclamation avant le programme à sion
c'est très facile ça faisait 6 2 3
discret alors maintenant pour terminer
voici les deux points ouvrez les
guillemets la petite phrase point fermez
les guillemets alors ça fait aussi
regarder ça fait deux points
ouvrez les guillemets la petite phrase
points fermez les guillemets à toute
vitesse a fait comme ça
vous êtes parent fallait pas venir c'est
pas grave on peut mettre en application
ce que nous venons de dire parce
qu'imaginez j'ai pas mal demain matin
mitterrand qui commencera fera un
discours en seize français imaginent là
où michèle voudriez voir la gentillesse
de ma portée oui s'il vous plaît un
livre ou une application
nous allons n'est ce pas mettre en
application ce que nous venons
d'apprendre à la dans un texte nous a
amené la vie de châteaubriant voilà la
vie de châteaubriant que m'a offert ma
petite maman il ya très longtemps à
point à point et jenny appoint de
chateaubriand à point oui c'est amusant
à langogne
alors là vous allez voir ça prend toute
sa dimension maintenant oui absolument
alors michel vous savez faire un point
vous la virgule c'est tout ce que je
sais faire
j'ai essayé le point d'interrogation
j'avais la qatar à l'écouté bien alors
écoutez bien alors voici donc un texte
de chateaubriand qui relate l'histoire
de lucien deux battants prix fou d'amour
pour la belle aurélie et le passage que
je vais vous lire c'est justement le
passage où lucien déclare sa femme à la
mairie sa flamme à auréline pardon et
voilà ce que cela dit sur le lac du bois
de boulogne
lucien deux battants près g
aurélie laisse glisser vers lui un
regard complice lucien s'arrête soudain
de ramé et s'écrit mon amour est ce la
première fois que vous aimez eux
auraient ligne
oui mais sial c'est merveilleux je
souhaite que ce soit la dernière fois un
grand silence s'installe en un instant
lucien est auprès d'aurélie
il la prend dans ses bras il embrasse il
la caresse
qu'est ce qu'il fait là aux origines
plusieurs mais que cet amour c'est ma
vie et sémaphores c'est ma raison d'être
non
à ces mots auréline se lève et dans la
fureur dans la fureur et dans la fureur
de leurs élans le chan ho et kavir le
canoë chappille emportant les amants
enlacés dans l'ondaine et faste